That doesn't look like something you want to use in your house.
You're gonna ruin your floors.
Put rubber on the floor,
rubber on the floor,
put rubber all over your house so nothing gets ruined.
Did you,
do you have grandparents who put plastic over the furniture?
Oh yeah.
My Nana.
My Nana in Clifton,
New Jersey.
Yeah.
My mind was in New York.
Yeah,
they put fucking plastic over the furniture.
It was a big deal.
You spent a lot of money on that couch.
You're gonna.
It's gonna has to last their whole life fuse where I was a little kid,
I'd sit on that couch,
I'll be like,
this is terrible.
Especially in the summer with your shorts and your,
the back legs.
Just be sweating it man.
And this.
And they eventually got kind of like yellowed by the sun and by use crackly.
So it was weird.
Yeah.
It was like,
oh,
you would like put like a jacket down and then he would sit on your jacket.
That whole generation never had comfort.
Like their beds were hard,
the pillows were shit like that.
Look up through the fucking depression,
man.
Yeah,
that's,
that's real,
that shit.
People Starve to death.
This was barbaric time where,
where people were brought down to,
you know,
base humanity just was rival rough.
And then you have like,
you have like 15 good years and then go into World War II and they dealt with
that.
So yeah,
they were like,
we don't need comfort.
We're not laying around in our sweat pants on bean bag chairs.
Will,
they knew the importance of being vigilant.
Right.
Like we all do.
Do you ever,
do you follow I'm David Goggins Online?
Yeah.
David,
do you know where he is?
No.
David Goggins is this navy seal who,
um,
now is more or less a,
uh,
like a motivational and a fitness influencer run.
The Guy who runs,
oh dude,
broken knees.
That was a fucking savage.
Yeah,
I've seen some of his clips.
How many?
100 mile runs that he'd run in a row.
Some fucking preposterous number.
Yeah.
I don't remember.
I don't want to say,
cause I can't remember it all.
I want to say six or seven.
But then it's like 12 or 13 of 100 mile member.
I don't remember it all but there his whole thing is stay hard.
Like he'll send me a text out of nowhere.
Like just say stay odd motherfucker.
Don't go soft out there.
Yeah.
Cause like first of all,
if you're a navy seal,
right?
This is the pinnacle of hand to hand combat and armed forces.
Those motherfuckers are all special humans.
Yeah.
And then on top of those motherfuckers being all special humans,
there's guys that can just just put a little of that message out like hey you,
you are soft as fuck compared to how people used to be.
Right.
All soft as fuck.
Compared to those world war two people,
those state,
you've got to stay vigilant.
Back then everybody had to stay vigilant.
Yeah.
You had to deal with just day to day life,
you have to deal with what was coming from Hitler,
what a tune in at a certain time to find out what was happening.
Yeah.
Everybody had to gather around the TV for the news.
That was all the news you got.
That's all the news you got.
You only got an hour's worth.
That was it.
They just know what the fuck was going on,
nothing,
nothing.
And they were better report and they may just say really whatsapp.
So tired of that.
They were better off for it.
I don't need to know.
Not better off for it.
Way Better off recognizing that you're luckier than those people having some
fucking discipline,
watching a David Goggins Instagram clip and get your fucking shit together.
Tom.
No,
I'm not.
I agree with everything you just said.
I agree with everything you just said,
but I'm saying you're better.
They were better off not being fed a news diet 24 hours a day.
Yeah.
Mentally,
mentally pour the first human beings that have had to deal with this onslaught.